[Musique]
alors s'il existe une un mouvement
politique qui a dû rompre avec le passé
pour émerger c'est bien le mouvement de
libération des femmes
lorsque en avril 1970
un petit groupe de femmes qui s'appelait
encore à peine mouvement libération des
femmes a voulu exprimer sa solidarité
avec les féministes américaines en grève
elles ont eu l'idée d'aller déposer une
gerbe sur la tombe de la du soldat
inconnu
et donc c'était un hommage à la femme
inconnue du soldat qu'est ce qu'elle
voulait dire par là elle voulait dire
que du point de vue de la société et
plus précisément de la nation la femme
était encore inconnu de la même façon
que freud avait dit que les femmes sont
le continent noir
hélas les femmes restent n'était jamais
récompensé par la nation pour leur
participation à l'effort de guerre
pendant la guerre de 14 par exemple et
pendant la résistance est donc là tout
d'un coup vous avez un groupe de femmes
qui arrivent il y a plus inconnu que le
soldat sa femme et donc c'était
émergence du mouvement de libération des
femmes dans la société française des
années 70 deux ans après mai 68 a été
comme une autre révolution parce que ces
femmes ont décidé de faire un mlf sans
les hommes c'est à dire que c'était un
mouvement non mixtes et ça ça a été très
important parce que à travers cette non
mixité s'est mis en place
ula sisterhood la sororité et ça c'était
très important parce que elles ont cessé
de se définir par rapport à l'homme par
rapport aux maris par rapport aux
modèles masculins qu'on nous présentait
comme le modèle que nous devions intégré
pourra être acceptée dans la société
mais elles se sont tournées vers les
femmes vers l'antre femmes vers soi même
qui nous sommes des femmes nous les
femmes
et c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
découvrir ensemble
voyez on pas de 1 milliard et demi de
femmes anonymes
c'était la femme est là nous allons nous
constituer comme les femmes toutes
différentes les unes les autres
mais qui sommes réunis par cette
nouvelle sororité en parallèle avec la
fraternité
1 nous on est en train d'établir à la
sororité et le torchon brûle évidemment
qu'est ce que c'est que le torchon assez
les travaux ménagers
c'est le travaux ménagers complètement
invisible que les femmes sont obligées
de faire dans le cadre de la famille et
du mariage
le premier recueil de textes qui a été
publiée par ce groupe de faim a été
intitulé libération des femmes 1 et 0
donc vous voyez cette rupture avec le
passé est vraiment tellement consciente
que elle n'avait pas l'impression d'être
les héritières d'un mouvement féministe
qui avait lutté par exemple pour le
droit de vote
n'oubliez pas que le droit de vote a été
acquis en 1944 seulement alors que dans
les autres pays il était déjà depuis
longtemps
non seulement le droit de vote mais
aussi la liberté de travailler sans
l'autorisation du mari la liberté de
prendre à un compte en banque sans
l'autorisation du mari la contraception
tout ça s'est fait avant 1970 mais nous
nous avions pas conscience que nous
étions les héritières c'est pour vous
dire à quel point cette transmission ne
s'était pas fait donc libération des
femmes année zéro et cette année zéro
c'est à bas la société mal
donc c'est une un mouvement qui va se
dresser contre le pouvoir masculin le
pouvoir masculin c'est à dire que tous
les postes dans la société sont occupés
par des hommes à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez très peu de femmes députées et
c'est valable dans tous les domaines y
compris dans les journalistes y avait
aucune femme journaliste dans les
rédactions qui pouvaient être envoyés
pour couvrir nos actions vous voyez
c'est très intéressant de voir comment
s'est mis en place une vraie un vrai
basculement du côté du féminin
donc à bas la société mal est aussi
grève grève des femmes
ça c'est en 1974 ou où nous avons bombay
dans le métro on y avait une grande
rencontre autour de la grève des femmes
c'était la première fois que des femmes
faisait un bon beh dans le métro 1 et
donc qu'est ce que c'était que cette
grève des femmes en 1974 c'était
évidemment le travail parce qu'on a on
était loin d'avoir à travail égal
salaire égal
mais c'était aussi la grève du lit grève
delà de la sexualité grève du travail
ménager 1 ne vouliez pas que ont défilé
dans les rues en disant double journée
demi salaire 1
la double journée entre parenthèses on
n'a pas fait beaucoup de progrès
et puis c'était de manière à
conscientiser que les femmes sont à la
base du fonctionnement de la société
c'est vraiment comme pendant le coc vide
on a pris conscience que les caissières
était absolument indispensable toutes
les femmes
les infirmières etc c'était vraiment
celle qui faisait marcher le pays
eh bien les femmes ce sont elles qui
font marcher la société et ça c'était
très important et ça a été le début
d'une prise de conscience qui n'est loin
d'être terminée donc deuxième rupture
qui a été fondamental avec le passé
c'est là la reprise en main de la
fécondité féminine c'est à dire que ce
ne sont plus les médecins c'est plus le
pouvoir politique qui va décider si on
doit faire des enfants ou pas ce sont
les femmes à travers un combat qui est
pas seulement le combat pour la
contraception qui venait tout juste
d'être votée par l'assemblée nationale
mais c'est le combat pour l'avortement
c'est à dire un enfant si je veux quand
je veux
et ça ce combat là il a été fondamental
parce que il a commencé en 1971 avec un
manifeste où 343 françaises ont dit je
j'ai avorté
et c'est cet interdit depuis la loi
mines
120 c'était une loi nataliste pour
repeupler la france après la guerre de
et là dans ce manifeste on prenait des
risques quand même considérable parce
que n'oubliez pas que sous l'occupation
il y à une femme qui a été décapitée
parce que elle pratiquer les avortements
et donc c'était interdit et les prisons
françaises y avait un tiers des femmes
en présent qui était pour avortement et
donc on prenait des risques mais en même
temps c'était une bombe dans la société
parce qu'enfin l'hypocrisie été révélé
au grand jour c'est à dire que toutes
les femmes qui mouraient pourra pour
avoir avorté et notre combat il a
débouché sur la fondation du mouvement
pour la liberté de l'avortement et de la
contraception qui celui là était mixte
avec des médecins et ensuite ça a donné
la loi veil en 1974 et 1975
donc la loi veil elle n'est pas tombée
du ciel c'est le résultat d'un combat
collectif déterminer très très important
et vraiment suivi par énormément de
femmes et donc il y avait un deuxième
problème qu'il fallait aussi prendre à
bras le corps c'est le problème du viol
vous avez vu tout à l'heure dans le
recueil de textes libération des femmes
mené 0 bien il y avait déjà un texte sur
le viol le viol ordinaires et en 1976
nous avons mené tout un combat contre
contre le viol parce que à cette époque
là le violent s'était jugé pour coups et
blessures et donc nous avons fait un
combat pour qu'ils soient jugés comme
crime et ça a été un très long combat
est ici vous avez un exemple typique de
l'atmosphère qui régnait dans les années
70 parce que on a organisé donc 10
heures contre le viol où beaucoup de
femmes ont témoigné et aux bouts à la
fin la fin de la soirée on a eu besoin
de danser on a tous dansé ensemble
moi je faisais partie
orchestre et donc leur castres a fait
danser vous voyez un peu l'atmosphère
qui régnait de sororité c'était ça la
solidarité qui a permis donc de mener un
combat et de d'un combat victorieux avec
gisèle halimi qui a été très importante
à la fois dans le combat pour
l'avortement et dans le combat pour
contre le viol puisque c'est elle qui
était l'avocate des deux jeunes belges
qui avaient été violées dans à marseille
donc vous voyez tout ça c'est l'héritage
que les femelles ont eu dans leur
berceau si je puis dire parce que
maintenant nous nous situerons dans les
années 2015
entre 1981 et 2015
il ya eu la gauche au pouvoir il ya eu
yvette roudy qui était ministre les
droits des femmes et vous avez eu toute
la politique du gouvernement d'égalité
pour les droits des femmes et c'est bien
que nous sommes passés d'une dynamique
de mouvement d'émancipation de
libération des femmes
c'est un processus c'est une libération
ce n'est jamais fini
on est passé à une politique d'égalité
des droits
c'est à dire quelque chose de beaucoup
plus statique si vous voulez au niveau
d'un mouvement politique parce que une
fois que vous avez les droits et ben
vous n'avez plus rien à faire et on
s'est rendu compte que si on avait
encore beaucoup à faire
et l'exemple des femen qui défilent
torse nu dans les rues en disant
permission de sortie ça veut dire que
les femmes n'avaient pas le droit encore
de sortir dans la rue que la rue ce
n'est pas un territoire des femmes c'est
le territoire masculin et donc c'est
comme ça qu'il ya le mouvement mis tout
est arrivé à partir des états unis 1 on
a découvert que finalement les femmes
les actrices elle avait beau être
célèbre gagner de beaucoup d'argent
elle était sous la pression des
prédateurs masculin pour leur donner du
boulot et donc toutes les femmes ont des
âmes et moi aussi moi aussi
j'ai subi de la pression moi aussi
j'étais victime de prédateurs et c'est
comme ça que ce moi aussi est devenue
nous tout est que cette prise de parole
collective c'est vraiment une prise de
parole qui a été en écho avec la prise
de parole des années 70 et ça c'est
important
et on se rend compte que dans notre
société et bien cette prise de cap de
parole elle n'est pas on doit la refaire
sans arrêt et en plus de ça le problème
c'est que la parole des femmes ne fait
pas autorité les femmes ne sont pas cru
quand on dit j'ai été violée hommes et
humainement qu'est ce que tu racontes
etc
ce n'est pas vrai donc il ya un problème
d'autorité de la parole des femmes et ça
c'est très important la prise de
conscience qui a eu lieu c'est qu' il
fallait maintenant que cette autorité
s'assoit sur un mouvement collectif qui
s'appelle le mouvement nous tout nous
tout moi aussi nous toutes et vous voyez
ici c'est la grande manifestation en
cinquante mille femmes dans la rue et
cette manifestation moi je dirais que
50000 fall ça existait aussi en 1979
quand on a fait la grande manifestation
pour le renouvellement de la loi veil et
on était cinquante mille dans les rues
de paris aussi mais ça on l'a oublié
donc vous voyez le problème de la
transmission de transmettre les luttes
sans arrêt nous on est obligé de
remettre sur le tapis
qu'est ce qu'on a fait et qu'est ce
qu'on n'a pas fait mais quelle est la
différence alors avec le les années 70
ici vous avez françoise d'eaubonne
françoise d'eaubonne qui est la mère de
l'écoféminisme françoise d'eaubonne elle
a écrit un livre en 1974 qui s'appelle
le féminisme ou la mort mais son livre
il n'a eu aucun écho dans la société
française il a juste eu un écho aux
états unis
et dans le monde anglo saxon pourquoi
parce que la société n'était pas prête à
faire une réflexion sur le sur la
présence de l'être humain dans son
milieu et sur la relation entre
l'exploitation du corps des femmes par
le patriarcat et l'exploitation de la
terre par le capitalisme et les co fait
minime c'est ça c'est ce que françoise
d'eaubonne a fait et donc elle est là
elle a fait cette conception elle a
conçu un mouvement qui saperait échos
féminisme et ce mouvement il a jailli
dans le tout le combat de mitu et c'est
ça qui est très intéressant parce que
c'est devenu un grand combat qui reprit
maintenant par les jeunes
vous voyez ici la manifestation à paris
ni les femmes ni la terre ne sont des
territoires de conquête et ça c'est très
important cette analogie entre les
femmes et la terre parce qu'on a dit que
pour les femmes la fécondité féministe
si on met la petite graine dans la terre
et donc la nature les femmes ont été
naturalisés mais aujourd'hui on est
obligé de repenser notre rapport à la
nature et notre rapport aux femmes est
la nature la femme naturelle
c'est-à-dire à l'intérieur d'une culture
qui est celle du changement de paradigme
de notre société et ça voyez tous les
jeunes ça c'est la grande manifestation
en 2019 pour la marche du siècle mais y
est tous les jeunes qui reprennent qui
découvre en fait qui découvre quelque
chose qui existait dans l'inconscient
collectif on peut dire parce que dans
l'histoire il ya toujours cette
intervention de l'inconscient collectif
par exemple on en a un autre exemple
avec les sorcières des sorcières elles
ont été poursuivies par l'inquisition ou
xviie siècle et brûlé pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles ont été brûlés parce qu'elle
tenait des secrets sur la nature des
secrets sur la vie des secrets sur la
santé par les plantes
elle était proche de la nature elle
était une
une concurrence au pouvoir des médecins
qui était en train de se mettre en place
dans les universités où les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit d'aller les
femmes n'avaient pas le droit d'étudier
à la sorbonne
c'était interdit et donc les sorcières
les voilà qui reviennent qui ré merde
et ça c'est la grande nouveauté
aujourd'hui avec le mouvement mitu qui a
permis sa et qui est mis en valeur la
puissance des femmes la puissance
invaincu des femmes et qui a mis we can
do it c'est à dire l'empowerment a donc
aujourd'hui les femmes ne rejette pas le
pouvoir
elle revendique la puissance et l ont
acquis la capacité en allant elle dans
les écoles en pénétrant dans tous les
milieux
parce que maintenant il ya plus de 2 des
spas ce qu'ils sont interdits aux filles
et donc elles ont elles ont hacké le
pouvoir de m powerpoint est alors donc
pour terminer je voudrais vous montrer
une sculpture de niki de saint phalle
qui pour moi est très importante parce
que c'est la culture
elle a mis en images la fertilité des
femmes et vous voyez elle a permis que
en 1967 dans une grande exposition
qu'elle a intitulé le pouvoir aux nanas
un don qu'elle a fait cette sculpture ou
rentrer à l'intérieur du ventre de la
femme et à l'intérieur il y avait des
styles j'avais une cuisine une salle de
bains etc
et qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit la
femme et la grande déesse de la
fertilité donc la fertilité des femmes
qu'elles soient qu'elle soit par la
maternité ou culturelles ou même
spirituelle elle est entre nos mains
maintenant et c'est à nous de l'exprimer
dans la société
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]